released just in time for comic-con
here's everything you might have missed
in the first trailer for Kevin Smith's
long-awaited Jay and Silent Bob reboot
as a wise man once said the title of Jay
and Silent Bob reboot tells audiences
exactly what it is a super meta reboot
of Smith's 2001 film Jay and Silent Bob
strike back in the original Jay and
Silent Bob strike back our dim-witted
stoner protagonists traveled to
Hollywood to shut down a movie version
of Bluntman and chronic a comic book
that imagines Jay and Silent Bob as
marijuana themed superheroes that film
was lampooning Hollywood adaptations Jay
and Silent Bob reboot is you guessed it
lampooning Hollywood reboots by using
the exact same plot the studio is now
rebooting the Bluntman and chronic film
so Jay and Silent Bob have to once again
go to Hollywood to stop it expect a lot
of fourth wall breaking inside jokes
where you guys figure out this review it
sucks
there I said it and who's directing it
anyway Kevin Smith Jay and Silent Bob
reboot looks to be a franchise capping
movie pulling characters from two
decades worth of interconnected Kevin
Smith movies rosario Dawson appears in
the trailer likely reprising her role as
Becky from clerks to Matt Damon found
one of his earliest roles in Smith's
Dogma and in Jay and Silent Bob reboot
he returns as Loki the avenging angel he
played in the latter
Damon's buddy Ben Affleck is also a
Smith veteran and he appears in the
trailer as Holden McNeil the comic book
artist who created Bluntman and chronic
in chasing Amy also on hand at that
convention Jason Biggs and james van der
beek the original Bluntman and chronic
from the movie inside of a movie in Jay
and Silent Bob strike back and in this
film as in the last Jay and Silent Bob
movie the heroes find out about the
movie version from comics lover Brodie
Bruce still portrayed by Jason Lee it's
not just old friends making cameos there
are plenty of new faces too in a cheeky
bit of self-referential humor form of
Batman Val Kilmer plays himself playing
blunt man with supergirls Melissa
acting as chronic in other cameos from
new cast members Danelle Rawlings from
Chappelle's Show heads up a SWAT team
Craig Robinson plays a judge Joe
Manganiello is a bailiff just in long
place a lawyer and Fred Armisen shows up
as an unlucky uber type driver even some
other famous screen stoners make an
appearance rappers Method Man and Redman
as well as the legendary Tommy Chong and
there are also some new characters as
well Shannon Elizabeth reprises her role
from Jay and Silent Bob strike back as
an old love interest of Jays but this
time she has a surprise two daughters
one of which is Jay's love child played
by Kevin Smith's actual daughter Harley
Quinn Smith everyone knows Smith is a
huge comic book fan so it's no surprise
that there are a ton of nods to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in the Jay and
Silent Bob reboot trailer Chris
Hemsworth famous for playing Thor in the
MCU shows up briefly Kevin Smith as
Silent Bob gets involved in some kind of
action sequence that finds him inside of
a high-tech suit clearly inspired by
Iron Man
David des small chin who portrayed
Russian hacker Kurt in the ant-man
movies makes an appearance as a
high-strung SWAT team member and just
like in an actual Marvel movie there's
even a Stan Lee appearance of sorts
Jason Lee can be seen wearing a t-shirt
bearing the face of the dearly departed
Marvel master and cameo King finally the
first and coolest cameo in the Jay and
Silent Bob reboot trailer isn't even by
a person it's by a rundown old building
yes fans of Kevin Smith's s universe may
recognize the building as the location
of Smith's first film the beloved cult
classic clerks we can't wait to see what
other Easter eggs await when the film
hits theaters on October 15th see you
there
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you'll miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]